make it easy to do business with you
when it's hard to do business you know
what's happening nobody's going to do
business with you
you want to reduce the barriers as much
as possible and make it easy for
customers to work with you it sounds
simple but so many companies
make huge mistakes in this field and it
blows my mind and i wanted to share a
quick example with you somebody's doing
it well and somebody's not doing it well
i'm gonna go to an app on my phone so uh
the one that i love is starbucks so i'm
gonna load this up here see if you guys
can see my apps here this is my home
page these are the apps that i use
on a regular basis so i've got
dropbox navigation camera feedly
starbucks play store facebook calendar
cineplex insta paper messaging evernote
site music drop and play settings and
memorize these are my favorite apps
so from a retail shopping experience
one of the ones that i use constantly is
starbucks so i have a starbucks on the
ground floor of my building i'm always
drinking starbucks i'll click on
starbucks
and the thing loads and in a few seconds
i can go
find my card
let's see
and this is my gold card i've got 37
bucks it automatically recharges for me
so it's super easy i can pay and it'll
scan my barcode and
i can get
out of the store quickly
okay so that's a great example one of
the main reasons why i like my cell
phone
i used to not be a cell phone guy and
it'd be hard to go back to not having a
cell phone anymore
because of the stupid starbucks app
that's how much i like this app because
carrying around the card i lost the card
one day and then it was really hard to
pay for my drinks
and so
the app
saved me that day and i
needed to have the app all the time with
me that's like this is a first world
problem right but uh anyway i love using
it it's really it's practical for me in
my daily life so this is a great example
here's a bad example this is one that
infuriates me on a regular basis it's
it's the pc plus points program this is
something that i think is only in canada
but uh anyway for those of you building
apps or trying to improve your customer
experience here's an example of what not
to do and hopefully you guys from pc
plus are watching this so you can fix up
your program
you will notice pc plus is not on my
home screen because i don't like using
them so if i go to my apps
let me load up my apps here they are i
went yesterday
so first of all look how long this thing
takes to load it's ridiculous i'm
sitting there trying to check out
need to pull up my points card program
it takes forever to sign in and then
sign in again
meanwhile i'm causing a huge lineup
okay
to actually get my card i can click on
this so i have
4 000 points there's my card
and the thing is you can't scan that
barcode
so the person has to type this huge long
number
into their computer and they always make
mistakes they've got to type it in four
or five times before they actually get
it
and most of the products in the store
don't even allow you to collect points
so i'm sitting there not sure if any of
these products that i've just bought
actually will give me points and i'm
thinking do i want to waste time trying
to load up my app trying for that person
to be able to
punch in the number for me all to get
zero points and cause a huge lineup
behind me of frustrated people this
happened to me last night so i'm i'm
frustrated pc fix your points program
card it's ridiculous
this should scan on any scanner my
barcode just like starbucks should be
able to scan in and track the points and
you should get points for everything
why do i have to only get points on
certain products anyway the program is
ridiculous
and so i don't use the card it's buried
on my apps it's not on my home screen
and i hate using it
if customers hate working with your
stuff guess what they're not going to
use it anymore
so make it easy to do business i'd love
to say hey i love my pc plus program
card i'm using it all the time like my
starbucks one it's on my home screen i
tell people about it i drive more people
to their stores
and instead i'm slamming them because
their product sucks and it wouldn't take
a lot of work to make it great
so look at your own
company look at your own products and
services and is it easy to do business
with you
or not try shadowing a customer for a
day go through their experience hire
somebody to look at your website or make
a phone call into your company and see
what their experience is like if you can
improve their experience you'll have a
dramatic improvement
in new business in referral business and
repeat business
for your company
and can literally make all the
difference in the world for you
believe
for those of you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
i'd love to hear what you have to think
if there's a program an app that's doing
a really good job for you leave it below
or one that sucks
that you got to tell the guys hey you
need to improve your app leave it below
too i want to know about those guys and
if you have a different question for
your business put in the comments
section i love seeing them come in thank
you so much and i'll see you soon